hi guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel today i have
a special guest um he is a rapper author
and political commentator with close to
half a million
twitter followers but actually the most
impressive thing i found
is that you are the world record holder
for women's
deadlift
um so it's talking like that so tell me
zubie
um how does it feel to be the strongest
woman
on earth i don't know if i'm the
strongest woman on earth
um i think i'm the strongest in the uk
though for sure
and um it feels good honestly i mean it
turns out i had actually been the
strongest woman for quite a while
but it wasn't until i sort of reached
down deep down
into myself and looked into my lived
experience and my personal feelings that
i was prepared to come out to the world
as the strongest woman in the world and
uh since then
my fan base has grown significantly um
i've achieved all sorts of
accolades and fame and financial gain
so female privilege is real um did you
train
super hard for this well i've been
training for
more than half of my life and um
[Music]
like i said i mean i actually broke the
british women's deadlift record more
than 10 years ago
but i wasn't aware of the fact until i
fully embraced this identity
and once i did as i said you know it's
uh
it's i've achieved a new level of fame
ever since so
it feels good um okay but in all
seriousness
how did that tweet come about like how
did you come up with that
um so for several years since about 2016
2017
i had been seeing this whole situation
going on with biological males competing
in female sports i'd seen it happening
in mma athletics
uh weightlifting handball
aussie rules football all sorts of
various sports and i was
relatively early on ringing the alarm
bell on this thing just kind of telling
people hey
if you allow people to literally
identify as whatever they want
then you're going to have a whole bunch
of dudes identifying as women
and obliterating them in their sports
right this is the logical conclusion
and i remember back in 2017 people
telling me that i was being
overly alarmist about it and oh come on
zooby that's not gonna happen so on and
so forth
and then um yeah i mean two years later
i became the british women's champion so
on the day that i tweeted it i'd
actually seen a couple stories that
morning
of this situation happening um in the
usa i think
two high school athletics events and
then there was something else that i saw
that day
and out of curiosity i just thought wait
i'm really good at deadlifting i wonder
what the british women's
deadlift record is and i looked it up in
my
weight class and it was 215 kilos
and my max is 275 so i was like oh okay
i can
i i my deadlift is more than 100 pounds
above
the current british women's record so i
actually had that video on my phone
already from one of my training sessions
uh in that video that went viral i was
doing 230.
um and so i just took that nine second
clip i posted it up on my twitter
i think i had 18 000 followers at the
time i posted it
and um i thought it was going to be you
know i thought okay i think this is
funny so a few other people are going to
find it funny
little did i know that that video was
going to be seen by
tens of millions of people all around
the world
and that was actually what introduced me
to
a lot of people um and then off the back
of that they discovered my music my
podcast
my commentary all the other things that
i actually do
beyond being the british women's
deadlift record so it was an
unorthodox way for people to discover me
but that's how these things happen
sometimes did you
actually legally try to change it uh no
i didn't
the deadlift was i think a lot of people
think that i entered a competition
like i entered a sanctioned competition
and i specifically did that no
that video was actually i think that
video may have even been from 2018. it
was just a video on my phone from one of
my previous training sessions
so i just posted it up there um like i
said not thinking that
it was going to go so far and yeah
it clearly made a point that resonated
with a lot of people all over the world
so
it's uh yeah yeah that's actually
how i discovered you and um i was
actually super appreciative because
i'm um i was a three sport college
athlete
so i did like basketball and i've always
said that if i played basketball with
guys i would never
i would have no opportunity in sports at
all
um you know i was pr i was pretty good
but
you know i'm 5 11 and a half that's like
in the top half a percent
for women dude like there's like that's
like 15 of guys
so i mean men and women are different i
mean i know that uh
this is a highly controversial point to
make in 2021 but um
you know we have our similarities but
but we are different backtracking
a little bit um i watched a couple of
your interviews on um
joe rogan and you were on the ben
shapiro show after that tweet
which is super cool congrats by the way
so i grew up in one town my entire life
and you grew up like all over the world
it seems like
yeah i was born in the uk i grew up in
the middle east in saudi arabia to be
specific
um when i was 11 years old i went to
boarding school out in the uk
my family background is originally from
nigeria when i was in saudi i went to an
american school i think i've been to
35 or 36 countries overall so yeah i'm
i've grown up
amongst a lot of different cultures and
then beyond that i've also traveled a
lot on
in you know independently both with my
music and outside of it
so i've seen a lot of the world and
there's a lot more to see so
i have a different perspective on a lot
of things from most people and i
tend to see things from a more sort of
shall we say global view
than someone who may have just grown up
in
you know the uk or just in the usa et
cetera so i think that's part of why a
lot of people are interested by some of
my perspectives and insights because it
comes from a
slightly different perspective and a set
of experiences really
so what what do you feel like is um
especially different from growing up
around the world like
is there um because that's so
interesting you grew up in saudi arabia
and england and i think of those
cultures as completely different
yeah they are very different in a lot of
ways um
everything from the legal system to the
role of religion and what religion is
predominant in the country
to the cultures and the traditions to
the climate
everything everything's really different
in in a lot of ways of course there are
similarities right human beings
are human beings all over the world so
you also one thing you learn when you
travel a lot
is yeah sure people are different and
cultures and ways of doing things can be
very different
but also human beings are really similar
in
a lot of ways when you kind of get
underneath some of the more superficial
stuff
in terms of what drives and motivates
people and
you know people have different ways of
working out how a society
should be run shall we say um
but the sort of goals tend to be
tend to be pretty similar i mean even in
any western country in any country right
you have people of different political
philosophies different religious
orientations different perspectives
different ideas and
majority of people you know i think we
sort of
lose this in some of these culture wars
and battles the majority of people do
sort of want mostly the same stuff not
always totally
um and have very sometimes quite
radically different ways
of how they want to achieve it um
but yeah it's a it's a really different
culture and society to grow up in
and even when i was there it was sort of
two worlds because you have the expat
community and
which is a little bit of a bubble and
it's the way things are done there are
closer to how they might be
in the usa or the uk for example the
what community
expats right like people who are there
from people who are living and working
there who are not saudi nationals
okay you know americans canadians
british people people from all over the
world even other arab countries
but they're living and they're working
there with their families so
the rules even that apply there are
different uh outside
in real saudi shall we call it but you
also venture out into real saudi so
you see you see both sides of it so i
grew up i mean i
moved there i lived there from the age
of one so all my earliest memories date
back to saudi arabia so
for me that was kind of the norm so from
a really really young age i was able to
see that and be surrounded by all
different types of people from the very
beginning
and just understand okay there isn't
just one way
of doing things you know it's not just
okay this is how stuff is done in the uk
and that's it and it's absolutely the
right way and it's that simple or okay
this is how things are done in the usa
and this is how it is and
it's 100 right and that's it's that's
you know it's it's more nuanced than
that and i think oftentimes
people's i mean obviously naturally
wherever you're born and raised
that's your tends to be most people's
kind of deep default right it's your
frame
it's your frame of reference so if
you've grown up in a certain place this
even even on a city level right i mean
if you grow up in
i don't know um san antonio texas
even right you may end up with a
different
set of norms to someone who grew up in
san francisco
california or new york city um you're
literally even in the same country
but there's a sufficient gap in the way
that things are done there and even the
culture
and even some of the laws etc that
you know someone who grows up in san
francisco might think it's
you know why does this person own five
ar-15s like
this going here right like why are they
so into god and guns and big trucks and
whatever
and then someone that person who grew up
in san antonio might be looking at san
francisco like whoa
you guys are you guys are weird over
there kind of thing and then on on a
country level on an international level
that gets more and more
significant um especially if you're
talking about say
middle eastern culture or you know saudi
culture specifically and the way of
doing things
even though the legal systems etc right
i mean one thing people tend to know in
the west about saudi is just
uh you know anything they perceive as
negative right anything that they
perceive as oh you know well
what about this law or what about this
one thing that happened here or whatever
and
people also like i get a lot of stick
for quote unquote defending saudi arabia
right because people in the west always
just want to crap on it and like make it
out like it's the
it's the worst and most brutal and most
barbaric place ever
despite it being safer than most western
places
actually i actually did not know that
yes
but people make it out like it's some
you know crazy war zone where you know
gay people are being thrown off roofs
every day and you know women are just
being attacked in the street or whatever
which is
nonsense um i understand where why
people think some of those things and
there are things that
you know there are very valid criticisms
of saudi arabia
or you know the government in particular
just like there are very
valid criticisms of the american
government or the british government
and any government right but we
understand that
the government and the people are two
different things right i mean if you
wanted to paint a really bad
picture of the usa and i mean there are
people outside the usa and even within
the usa who do this right where
they just focus on the worst things that
have ever happened
in u.s history and the worst actions
taken by the government even in our own
lifetimes
and you can paint like a really really
awful picture
of america right you can paint it out to
be this horrible
white supremacist institutionally
systemically
structurally racist country which was
built off the back of
slaves and they're just bombing all
these middle eastern countries and
they're doing that right yeah you could
you know they're having school shootings
you've got people running around just
shooting right you can make the usa
sound like a really really
terrifying scary place and i mean and i
know people who are like oh my gosh i
would never go to the usa because yeah
they believe all this right and i'm like
uh if you go there it's actually you
know people are pretty cool like people
right people are just having shootouts
in the street or whatever and you know
it's the same
it's it's the same in saudi right are
there certain
laws and rules and things that i don't
personally
agree with or certain things which i
think okay this is an
area where it should be changed or it
should be you know made more liberal
shall we say etc yeah absolutely
are there also some things in the west
that i think should be more
i don't know conservative shall we say
yeah then i'm also like yeah you know
but
i see the i see the nuance in it right
and i'm not gonna
you know it's it's the same like i've
never been to i've never been to china
before
right i have a lot of criticisms of the
chinese government right
but i can separate that from
[Music]
chinese people as a whole right like 1.4
billion people in china
right all right a lot of them also have
problems with their government just like
people in the uk have problems with the
government
it's not right these these are separate
things so
i think you can condemn certain actions
taken by governments or politicians or
you know some certain attitudes that are
maybe somewhat pervasive in certain
societies without
it being as simple as uh we're the good
guys and they're the bad guys and
and that's it it's like i understand why
people want to think that way but it's
not
it's not really accurate and it also can
be very ignorant especially if you're
talking about a place
that you haven't even stepped foot in
you know you've just read a couple
articles online
and decided to hold a super strong
opinion on it
right you were actually um the first
person i've heard say anything positive
about saudi arabia
in my life um i don't know much about it
but
um the only things i never heard are
that like women just recently got to be
able to drive
and like women can't do certain things
is that true at all
yeah so i think um
i think women driving was legalized in
i want to say around 20 maybe 10 years
10 years ago or so
i think about 10 years ago um so
yeah i was like i hate driving to be
honest
[Laughter]
the men can drive me around like that's
fine actually
no i was i was talking to someone about
this the other day i was like feminism
got it all wrong we didn't have to work
we didn't have to do this
i'm gonna just show that home yeah
i often joke that um feminism was the
patriarchy's greatest invention
well and they even i was even joking to
someone the other day
like everything's automated now at home
every year you know
you could have been chill a dishwasher
it could have just been chilling
hey apparently apparently women wanted
i'm still not
i'm still not sold on the fact that most
women actually wanted that but um
you know that's what the indoctrination
says so so i mean yeah
you know they're like i said there are
elements of truth to a lot of things so
there are you know there are rules in
saudi
which there's no question that
um in countries like saudi and most of
the middle east
there are rules that do that are
discriminatory based on who people
immutably are right which i am
obviously opposed to right
at the same time i understand
this is and this is not uh sort of a
justification it's more of an
explanation
of why a lot of things are like that
there i mean lots of things are changing
even in the
uh 11 13 years since i left i think it
seems like things have changed quite
significantly so i'm quite curious to go
back and see what it's like now
um but the thing is in saudi you have to
remember that
there's no separation between church and
state
oh okay okay so in the in the whole west
you have this concept of
religion and state slash government
being separate right and
we are you're in a democracy right you
vote
for the leaders and you have different
political parties and you vote et cetera
right
saudi is a monarchy okay okay still it's
one of the few
proper monarchies that still exists in
the world so there isn't a
prime minister or you know there aren't
these political parties that you vote
for or whatever it's just there's a king
there's a prince there's the royal
family i mean the country is named after
the royal family
the house of saud right saudi is it's
the only country in the world i believe
that's named after a family
um so that's part of it and then the
laws are just based on
the religious laws so if you imagine if
you had like a christian theocracy
and the the laws of the land are
literally just
the biblical laws then
right then that's essentially what a
country like saudi arabia
is for the most part right so there's
not that
there's not that delineation um between
that i mean there's places that are more
hardcore such as um i think like
pakistan
uh iran etc right where some you know
it's it's it's even it's more shall we
say conservative even
in saudi arabia in many regards but
um you know these are things that are
changing over time so that that's just
for people to understand
why it's like that because again most
people have the default assumption of
okay you know
we know how things are in like a sort of
liberal democracy shall we say
um but then i'm like okay i get that but
you have to understand
over there the whole foundation
is is different so it's just it's just
coming from like a totally different
place so
for example you were talking about women
you know not not being able to drive
previously right that's like ultimately
based and backed up by
uh you know stuff within their religion
which you know like i said people are
you know very open to you know there's
people there
who will who will even be critical of it
etc
but it's just explaining that not every
you know different
cultures and societies just have
different ways of doing things you've
seen in the past and even now
you know if you look at china china
biggest country in the world right
the way they do things is in terms of
the government right
i mean their government is called the
chinese communist party right like it's
still one of the last roommates like the
biggest country in the world
is run by a communist party right so
it's collective there's elements of
capitalism now but it's much more
of a collectivist mentality it's not
this like individualistic
what's best for each individual maximize
each individual's freedom
like things are at least supposed to be
in the west over the past year and a
half that's changed a bit but
that's kind of what that's what it's
supposed to be whereas someone like
somewhere like china
or if you know we went back to the
soviet union etc it's
it's a much more collectivist mentality
and again like
i'm critical of this it's just
explaining
why it's like that because if you can
understand why
then yeah you can at least see it
beyond that sort of superficial level of
okay it's just that so
that's just how things how things
operate you know
so um i'm actually curious what brought
your parents there because
i just assume everyone that went to
saudi arabia goes to that goes to saudi
arabia goes there for
for oil is that a correct or incorrect
assumption
it's ultimately it's mostly correct okay
um
so there's a company called i mean in
saudi the i don't know if you know
that the most valuable company in the
entire world is
saudi aramco which is the biggest oil
company in the world um
higher net higher uh market cap than
apple google all of them um
so that is the
biggest company in the country i believe
there's other oil and natural gas
producers as well so
most people who go there as um
expats uh or you know really like
immigrants immigrant workers
they go to work for yeah in the oil and
natural gas field natural resources
and then on top of that um if you of
course you've then got
thousands to millions of people working
there and then of course you need
teachers you need doctors
i.t workers so on and so forth so my dad
is a medical doctor
so he was essentially a doctor he was a
doctor for
this company so he was a doctor for an
oil company right
so that's how it works so where i live
basically everybody was
everybody was either an engineer a
doctor
or a teacher or some kind of like i.t
worker that was pretty much it because
that's like all they need and then they
have their families
so all my friends parents were like in
one of these fields pretty much oh okay
so
um was it so i know in some countries
like when people immigrate there it's
very
separate with like the communities like
it's more um
like there's the americans and then
there's the people that are from that
country is that what it's like in saudi
arabia
yeah yeah very much so so that's what i
was saying about having the sort of
uh bubble so you've kind of got the
uh expat community bubble and then you
have
what i'd call like real saudi arabia
which is outside of that
so yeah it's very much um it's very much
like that
um and so where i lived lots and lots of
americans which is why i even sound how
i sound
um canadians british people people from
all over the
arab world syria jordan
um you know saudi itself bahrain uae
lots of lots of different places and
then you know also other african
countries other asian countries quite a
lot of people from the philippines and
india
pakistan just people from all
people from all over the world um so
yeah where i lived was i mean if you saw
where i lived
you kind of went in you'd think you're
just in some suburb in like california
or
texas or something like that um but then
you'd go if you go outside of that
then you're like okay like you're in
proper saudi or if you want to go out
shopping say and you want to go into the
city
like you know go to go two hours out go
shopping in the city and alcobar or
whatever it is
then yeah like you experience more
of what the real saudi your baby is like
and
how old were you when you left
um so i went to boarding school at 11
and then
i my family moved to the uk permanently
when i was about 20
20 21. okay was that scary to be shipped
off to england at 11 years old
at 11 honestly no for me no um probably
for a lot of kids it would have been
but for me uh i just was excited about a
new adventure
so no i don't think i cried once i don't
think i got homesick once
wait so we're your parents they weren't
with you then no they weren't saudi
arabia
wow i might i would i would have
it's not it's not for everyone did you
not see them for years then
no i'd see them three times a year so i
go back
during the vacations okay and then i was
flying by myself
from the age of 11 from the age of 11 to
12 i was like you know
going on planes and traveling
internationally by myself
and then you went to oxford i did
how was that what's that like i just
imagine a lot of
smart people like walking around talking
about
super smart stuff i don't know what yeah
um yeah oxford is
very how would i put oxford i mean it's
a cool have you ever been to the city
um like any city oh no no like oxford
itself
no i've never been no i've never been to
england i have been england okay so
oxford is a real it's a beautiful city
um it's one of the oldest universities
in the world of course so there's
the architecture is absolutely stunning
really really beautiful architecture
um you're surrounded by some of the
smartest people in the entire world
all the time which is pretty cool and
you have interesting
conversations and stuff like that and
i've made a lot of great friends there
i studied computer science which i
didn't necessarily love my course
that much but um you know i made it
through and the overall experience was
positive
um if i went if i could go back i
probably would have done a different
subject
okay um i like the university and i like
the city a lot
okay i was actually going to ask you if
you would recommend college for doing
what you do now
for doing what i do now yeah no no not
at all
no i mean i'm a rapper a podcaster
author like
what i do doesn't require or necessitate
that
so i think i mean my to honestly my view
on college slash university has changed
a lot
over the past
10 to 10 to 12 years it's changed quite
significantly
so i only recommend university for
people who fit into a certain
couple certain categories and outside of
that i don't really recommend it
um i do fit into those categories and i
didn't know what i was gonna
when i went to university i wasn't doing
what i'm doing now so i didn't know i
would
and also universities to open doors
rather than to close existing ones
but um yeah i mean if someone wants to
do what i do in general then you
certainly don't need a degree for it
okay so what was your first job
um i've only ever had two jobs
okay i'm not someone who's got this like
a long streak of jobs that i've done
so when i was a teenager i worked
in the school in saudi arabia for a
while like during summer holidays just
helping out with various stuff so i
guess technically that was a job
and then the only so-called real job
i've had was being a management
consultant
so i used to work for a big management
consulting company for three years
um i was based in london but i traveled
around quite a lot
for it and then um i mean i've been
full-time self-employed
since november 2011 now so
coming up to 10 years oh wow so yeah
yeah i've been self-employed for almost
10 years so apart from those two those
those are the only jobs
i've the only forms of employment i've
ever had beyond being self-employed
uh so did you always want to be a rapper
or did that come later
i started rapping in university okay i
started wrapping i started rapping in
oxford
um i released my first album when i was
in my second year of university
so i started rapping in my first year
and then about 10 months in
i put out my first album and that was
the sort of spark of like oh
okay this is something i can i can do
and take more seriously as a career
and then actually the year after i
graduated i did my music full-time for
one year i released a second album and
then i moved to london
uh joined the corporate world like i
said worked in that for three years
and then i got to a point where both
careers were starting to conflict with
each other so much and
ultimately i knew what i wanted to do so
it wasn't a hard decision
some people are like oh it must have
been so hard for you to quit your job
and
go pursue music or whatever i was like
honestly it wasn't man
honestly it wasn't i i just did it i
knew what i wanted to do i knew where my
heart was i knew where
i know i knew the impact i wanted to
have on the world and there was no way
that i was going to make it
um doing a traditional
job or working in the corporate world i
mean the concept of me even working
corporate now like i can't even
fathom it like i'm so far yeah i'm so
far removed from it now
that i'm basically just unemployable you
know i just do my thing and i love doing
my thing
and a lot of people love me doing my
thing
so yeah yeah i i can't i can't imagine
going back to that kind of thing i'm
born to be an entrepreneur you know
right i've been selling stuff since i
was a kid i've always been like
that guy who has like side hustles and
is always
flipping stuff and making money and you
know all legal by the way
um i'm just wired that way i'm wired
that way i'm not wired to like
work underneath people were you uh
you're because i think you're a little
bit older than me so i was gonna ask if
you were the facebook marketplace guy
was that the facebook marketplace guy
what do you mean
i feel like there's always one guy in
high school that was always flipping
stuff on facebook
oh okay uh facebook marketplace didn't
even exist when i mean
facebook was invented in my first year
of university
so yeah 2004
um so yeah facebook marketplace didn't
even
exist until i was well out of university
um so did you have like a following
before that tweet blew up
that was pretty decent um
yeah yeah across social media i had
about 50 000 followers
at the time um so i mean by the time
that tweet came out i mean i put out
five albums and three
and three eps done four tours um
performed in eight countries i mean i've
been doing my music for
over 10 years by that point so
especially
in the uk you know a good number of
people knew me here from
all my music and then that just exposed
me to a whole different audience and
took it more international
and then all my appearances on you know
joe rogan and ben shapiro and the reuben
report
and fox news sky news bbc all these
things just
started to get me out to way way way way
more people
um and my new album word of zubi which
is uh
you know that's really my first proper
music release
since all of this stuff blew up in the
way that it's done
so my audience in reach now is just at a
whole
whole different level to where it was
you know two and a little bit years ago
so it's been it's been a wild ride and
it still is how many
uh a lot of um a lot of my
followers are looking to get into social
media like a good chunk of them
okay and one of the questions that
someone wanted me to ask you is how many
followers
do you think you need to quit your job
it has nothing to do with how many
followers you have okay what does it
have to do with
how much money are you making okay fair
enough
you can have 200 you can have a million
followers and be
broke and you can have 10 000 followers
and be making seven figures a year
and i know people in both of those camps
really yes so that people that have
millions of followers that aren't making
any money
well you have to make you you don't just
make money by having followers do you
right yeah so you have to offer a
product or service and people have to
buy it
no uh no my boyfriend he doesn't do that
but he makes like a ton of money off
of social media oh yeah no he's he must
he just gets brand deals yeah well
that's
yeah well that's that's selling
something that's selling okay it's
advertising
okay yeah fair enough yeah that's
advertising so i mean you you've got to
be
you've got to be selling some type of
product to service i mean if you if for
brand deals
then i mean it even depends on what
niche you're
in right um and just having all you know
having
a hundred thousand followers even
doesn't necessarily even mean you're
going to get
right reaching out to you it depends on
what you're doing and who your audience
is and if there's a particular brand
that it fits etc so
um i think whoever is asking that
question is looking at it the wrong
way the wrong way yeah they're looking
at it the wrong way
um they need to be thinking about
followers and themselves
it's kind of it's a bit of a vanity
metric right it's not just about the
width
it's also about the the depth of the
relationship so i mean you could have a
million followers
and they don't care to buy anything from
you
yeah or you know brands don't care to
sponsor you or whatever it is
but then you could have a much smaller
following i mean there's people with 20
000 followers who are
you know 10 000 followers but those 10
000 people are very engaged and perhaps
they're perhaps they're in a specific
niche
so whether it comes to brand deals or
selling them something directly they're
going to get very high conversion rates
and they're going to do very well um if
you have you know 100 000 followers or
half a million followers but they're
just very
lukewarm i mean you've probably seen
this on social media you've probably
seen
giant accounts you know two million
followers and they get like no
engagement
right yeah or you've seen people with
you know 100th of that
and they get massive engagement yes so
all of these things matter it's not just
as simple as
accumulating numbers um
so yeah that's a long-winded answer to
that so
do you recommend people niche down or
because what i liked about you
is you were one of the first people that
was actually doing what i wanted to do
because i have like a wide var variety
of interests i really like
politics and economics like i studied
econ in school i love
music and um i also just love
well i love like i do pranks sometimes
sometimes too
but um but um what i liked about you is
you were doing different
things so i was just curious if you had
did that help you or hurt you do you
feel like diversifying
so many different things definitely
helped definitely helped
but it depends on it depends on who you
are and it depends on
what interest you have and what people
value
and also how good you are at those
things yeah right like
everybody has lots of interest it
doesn't mean that you know you could
have an interest that
is not monetizable in every proper way
yeah right you know there's a lot of
people who are interested in sports but
it doesn't mean they can all be
professional
athletes or even yeah necessarily sports
commentators or or coaches or whatever
it is you know you might be
if you can find that intersection
between what you're passionate about
what you're good at and what there's
actually demand for then you've won
right very few people in the world hit
all three of those if you can hit all
three of those
then you are way
ahead of the game in terms of being
successful
and being able to just enjoy your life
right and not feel like you're just
grinding and grinding and grinding
and um and it can take a lot of grinding
and grinding and grinding for that to
pay off i mean people need to remember i
put out my first album in 2006
right we're now in 2021 15 years on
and last year was the first year where i
made
more money doing what i do now than i
would have done if i just stayed in my
corporate job
so that'll give people some perspective
okay right so people don't just think oh
look zooby just showed up and all of a
sudden he's crushing it it's like
no dude like for the past 10 years i
would have been
caking way more by just doing the suit
and tie stuff
than doing what i do now and now now
that's flipped and it's flipped
pretty aggressively um but that took
a long long time a lot of a lot of grind
a lot of legwork a lot of pain
um and you know and keep in mind most of
my efforts were in the real world it
wasn't just online
i'm talking like i've been in pretty
much every city in this whole country
multiple times spent thousands of hours
just
talking to people passing out flyers
selling cds on the street i mean
before people knew me for all this i
mean i was known for having sold over 20
000 albums independently on the streets
of england
right just going out there talking to
people i say england i mean i went to
scotland and wales too let me say the uk
they're talking to people i've spoken
over half a million people face to face
promoting my music hustling promoting
myself
city to city to city done over 100 shows
different cities different countries
performing to dead crowds performing to
nobody
performing to big crowds all sorts all
sorts over the past
decade plus and by the time a lot of
people discovered me
all that work had already been done it's
a little bit like
one of my friends actually made a really
good point with my deadlift video that
went viral right
which is that people saw that nine
second video but they didn't see the
training it took to be able to deadlift
a quarter of a ton
yeah right so they saw that video and
it's like oh anyone can do that i'm like
okay you lift it
right anyone can do that it's like all
right you lift that
it took 10 years to even be able to make
that video yeah so that's a good
metaphor
for actually the sort of trajectory of
everything that's actually one thing
i've noticed a lot
people that blow up in like in quotes
overnight
it's never overnight there's always more
to it than you think
there is and even and in the rare
moments
where it is somewhat overnight they're
also gone overnight
really always right so in situations
where someone genuinely just blows up
super quickly out of nowhere
then they never last and they see in in
music and anything
do you see the demilios um do you know
who they are
demilios i don't know oh my gosh you
don't
i'm shocked um they're you're not you're
not on tick tock are you
no unfortunately oh okay you say
fortunately
yeah oh i love tick-tock um
no it's this girl she's like 16 and she
went
from zero to 120 million followers
okay which is good yeah which is insane
so i wonder when you built a platform
that big
how does that go away overnight um
well what if tick tock dies in two years
i mean that's possible
yeah i mean look there's i mean if you
think back to the big youtubers back in
the day
yeah a lot of them most of them are gone
like remember who is if you remember who
was pop in like in i don't know 2010
like early big youtubers a lot of them
went away i'm not saying like in every
single case like in her case if she's
smart and she's able to sustain that and
she's built
some proper depth with her audience then
she'll be good right even if tick tock
dies
she'll shift to another platform and
she'll entertain people elsewhere i
don't even know what she does
um but obviously she's got some talent
to be able to do that
yeah so um in so that that can
definitely be done
but generally with a lot of things it's
it's
easy come easy go that that's the
general
that's the general thing right i mean if
you look at the world of music look at a
musician who
oh their first single just blows up okay
right
versus the artist who oh their 30th
single blows up right because then
they've already they know how to do live
shows
they know how to perform they know how
to write songs like they didn't it
wasn't a fluke they've put in all that
work
they've built their mindset they've
created some depth with their fan base
they've built credibility etc
so that when they get that break cool
like they're around you know ed sheeran
is going to stick around until he's in
his 70s if he wants
right i mean i knew about ed sheeran i
discovered ed sheeran in 2008
like many i remember when i had more
twitter followers than him
um you know like i've you know chatted
with him online before
so but he put in you know a good decade
pretty much before he
kind of blew up to the level and it's
the same whether you're talking rappers
or singers or whatever
the people who tend to really last can
have these multi-decade careers
it generally took them some real grind
and leg work to get there and then it
means that they're prepped and they're
ready
i mean it's it's like me now i mean if
i don't know say in 2009 i'd had
that video blow up in 2009 not that it
was possible because you know men were
still men and women were still women in
2009
but if i'd had that opportunity to even
go on joe rogan and go on ben shapiro
and do this and do that
i wouldn't have been i wasn't ready
right like i wasn't ready even just as a
human being
i wouldn't have been like the way i'm
talking to you now on this podcast if
you spoke to me 10 years ago i wasn't as
articulate and able to condense these
thoughts and i didn't have all this
experience to even draw on
and talk about in in anything or when it
comes to live performances right i mean
if someone blows up off their first
single and you're like hey we're gonna
put you on a festival come perform to
twenty thousand people
they're gonna suck right they haven't
performed yet right like they're
they're they're a noob right it's like
okay like
first day in the gym we're just gonna
whack on you know 100 kilos on the bench
press
and just you you're right you're going
to get flattened because
you can't skip experience you know you
can't skip experience right like the
only way you get experience is by doing
something
a lot of times right if you put out a
video or a podcast or something and like
your first one just
gets lucky and somehow catches the
algorithm and it blows up
you don't know how to capitalize on it
right you see this on twitter right
you'll see a tweet go viral
and it gets a hundred thousand likes you
click on the person's following
and they have like 800 followers i'm
like dude if that were me i would have
turned that 800 into 20 000.
but they don't do it i don't know how to
do it because
they just got lucky right they're just
lucky they caught the lightning
and they don't know how to actually
use these opportunities that they get i
mean i so i when i had that flash in
2019 i mean
it's funny that we're still that we're
even talking about it right because yeah
that tweet was over two years ago
oh wow yeah it is right and people
didn't just forget about zooby after
that
yeah it wasn't just like oh you know
tweets go viral every single
day yeah but everyone is not parlaying
that
into hundreds of thousands of followers
and releasing books
and podcasts and doing this and doing
that and getting on rogan and getting on
this and getting on that right it's like
you have to be able to do that but for
me to
for me like i i knew i was ready right
for like
i'd been ready i'm like oh man i've been
ready for like i've been ready for like
uh i don't know it's come 2009 i'm like
okay i've probably been ready for like
five years alright i need that
right give me that crack and i'm gonna
kick the door down right
give me that opportunity and i will kick
the door down right give me the
opportunity to perform in this place i
will blow that crowd up
give me that opportunity i will um but
at the early stages even though
we always want you know we all want
success immediately yeah
we want it yesterday but i mean it's no
different to any other career i mean
think about it
how in in what career do you expect to
get hired and become the ceo within two
years
none right like crazy person like no
right you're not going to get hired by a
company and you're like okay cool so i
want to be partner
like in 18 right right but people will
jump on youtube and be like okay like i
want to blow up in a year
right like man like you know i'm not
saying it's impossible
right right people have blown up in a
year yeah but it is not the norm like
talk to anyone on youtube who has even a
hundred thousand plus subscribers let
alone a million plus
right and see how long they've been
going like normally
again normally at least five years
often closer to ten right well the
reason i
asked this question is i just see i've
seen so many um just being on tic tac
i've seen so many tick tockers blow up
and get more followers than like people
have that have been working for 10 years
sure have got do you know what i'm
saying so it makes sense no i don't i
don't doubt it i mean yeah like i'd say
firstly a lot of them
i'm sure are not making a lot of money
some of them will be
a lot of them right a lot of them won't
be making money
um and two you know we can come back in
2025
and see how many of these you know do
you remember do you remember vine
no i never had it okay well where are
where are all the vine stars
i don't know nor do i okay
where are all the m where all the
myspace okay space stars right so
you know and a couple have stuck around
you know like jake paul used to use vine
and he was able to parlay that into a
gigantic youtube following and obviously
like he but he's again he's smart he
knows how to
capitalize on that so whatever platform
you give him
he's going to know what to do and you
know whether love him hate him whatever
he and his brother know you know they
have very smart marketing and branding
minds they know how to do it they know
how to monetize they know how to catch
attention
so on and so forth um but the truth is
like you know there have been
other platforms before you know i mean
vine was kind of like tick tock before
tick tock really
okay and even even snapchat like
snapchat is still
around but it's not it's already peaked
okay right yeah actually that's true
yeah so like there were big snapchat
stars right like the masters and they
got on like really quickly they kind of
blew up build a
big following but it just wasn't
sustained so much so i think
you also have to learn those kind of
fundamentals because different platforms
work well for different people obviously
like twitter is my best platform but
if you know twitter somehow goes the way
of the dodo i have built enough you know
knowledge and ex
like it would be a blow but i've built
enough knowledge and expertise and
audience etc so that
okay i know i understand the sort of
fundamentals as to
why i was successful there and how i
built that audience and it was it wasn't
just luck
it was like okay cool there's a strategy
there so then if you can apply that
to different things then i think you're
i think you're always good
um but yeah i would say you know what i
mean and i'm not saying like i hope
these people like i say i don't use tick
tock
like i hope these people who are getting
these millions and millions of followers
on tick tock i do genuinely hope that
a lot of them are able to
capitalize on that properly and turn it
into something long and
sustainable um but people need to
do that deliberately rather than kind of
just
stumbling into it and not really knowing
how they how they stumbled into it
yeah um no the main reason i wanted to
get your opinion on that is because i
haven't followed any social media people
long enough to know who sticks around
and who does okay so i actually don't
really know um it's very i'll tell you
it's very easy to see on
on youtube in on youtube twitter and
instagram it's very easy to see
actually because they've been around and
facebook as well because they've been
around for
long enough that you can see i mean if
you go back if you go on a big
youtuber's channel i mean you can go
back and watch their first videos in
most cases yeah
so you can see oh wow this guy's first
video was in 2005. so this guy's been
going for 16 years
and like they've really really really
built this thing
up you know um just like with music you
can go back okay when did this guy
release it first out oh wow okay this
guy's been going for
maybe i just heard about him today but
like she's actually been going
for a really long time or same with
podcasts etc
um so that actually leads into my next
question of your success
what percent would you um say is hard
work
luck or talent if you had to give a
percentage to each
um wow that's a good question i've never
been asked that
um hard work luck and talent
i'm going to say it really depends on
how i
think about it because it depends on
kind of how far back
kind of depends on how far back you go
right like does luck include the fact
that i was born
in the internet age and to a two-parent
household
in the western world right no no or are
we just talking like yeah you know what
i mean
i'm talking luck as in um you were born
like
just against everyone that was born in
present day
gotcha okay i will say
um
let's say let's say like
65 35
60. i said um hard work luck and talent
yeah 65 35 percentage okay
yeah sixty-five percent hard work five
percent luck and thirty-five percent
talent
oh i just can't do math
you were looking at me mad weird i was
like did i like yeah
i
[Laughter]
um have you ever thought about moving to
the u.s
yeah um i've actually applied for a visa
most people don't know that but um
hopefully i'll get a visa next year
we'll see what so when would you move
hypothetically
um we'll see um possibly next
year um but it depends i mean i'm
digitally i'm
i'm location independent now so
i don't i'm not tied to any country or
city
sort of per se so um
we'll see uh this is actually my last
week in the uk
for the foreseeable future
in terms of like living living so we'll
we'll see man we'll see i don't know a
lot of things up in the air but
it's possible okay yeah
um so i need to know i've been dying to
ask you this question what are your
thoughts on kevin samuels do you know
who that is
yeah yeah he's dope um he's funny and i
think he's necessary
i think the world has gotten so obsessed
with
lies and delusion that we need more
truth tellers
and um you know he can occasionally be a
little bit savage with it
but that's probably necessary because
it's gone so far in the opposite
direction
that we need some people who just cut
through the bs
and tell people what they don't want to
hear but should hear
yeah um the red pill is so interesting
there aren't a lot of girls that watch
it
or know what it is so uh
yeah i mean most people in general don't
i think that's why it's called
the red pill oh like the matrix
yeah like most people are in the blue
pill world right so the whole metaphor
is
if it were like fully mainstream then
it would probably need a new probably
need a new title by then
so um one of the guys wanted to ask you
what dating advice you'd give to young
guys
oh wow um
that's so general is there is there a
more more specific or is it just
just that job no no man folk honestly
focus on yourself dude
focus on yourself don't just chase women
like become an
awesome man and women will eventually
chase you um like focus on
focus on yourself and focus on becoming
a guy
who is attractive
and you know a valuable person to
society and to everyone around you
and who is competent and who's skilled
and talented
and who has some semblance of resources
and then um yeah like that that's really
the the main the main focus and then
beyond that
you know if you're interested in a girl
like let her know you know don't
be a don't be a wuss like
be you know go go go for as
a man you have to you know
as a man like nothing good in the world
happens to you
just by accident right you have to
you have to go out there and you have to
make it happen
like men put their will onto the world
right so you whether you're talking
health wealth success finances
relationships whatever it is
you're you're not going to just like
stumble into
oh i oh look i tripped up and i'm
suddenly rich or i tripped up and i'm
suddenly ripped
all right oh wow i accidentally you know
me you know sometimes sometimes yeah
maybe there's some guy out there who you
know
accidentally got a really hot girlfriend
or whatever but like
generally you you have to
turn your you have to use your own will
and your own skills and your own efforts
to make things happen that's just how it
is being
you know a person to a degree but
certainly being being a man in the world
so
my advice would be as a young guy you
know primarily
don't don't waste all your time in all
your hours you know just chasing and
chasing and chasing
women um chase success and
yeah let women eventually be a byproduct
of that
um i was gonna ask you would you give a
women different dating advice than men
yes what would you tell women to do well
i would say that women in general and
again i'm being
intentionally broad here someone's right
stop generalizing right
right um but in general women attract
things in the world right like women
women women attract
like i was saying men impose their will
on the world
right and a woman can in certain in
certain areas right you know like in the
workplace or you know in her career
whatever she may do the same
but certainly when it comes to some
other aspects like
women are more like women women can
afford to be more
passive shall we say right and attract
things
to them as we know generally in dating
and relationships like it's the guy
who is the active pursuant right whether
it's
approaching the woman you know making
the first conversation
you know paying for the date you know
deciding where to go on the day
it's proposing like it's the guy who
yeah is the active participant right and
it's women who are really like kind of
like
no no no yes no right
yeah i say men pick women shoes right
that's really that's the reality
of it and you know anyone who exists in
the real world whether or not they like
these kind of conversations
that's just the reality of it so
as a woman um yeah i would say that my
advice would absolutely be different and
i think people
do a massive disservice when they act
like men and women are
yeah identical and the advice for men
and women should just be
the same just you know oh yeah just do
what a guy would do it's like
no there's an overlap right
self-improvement self-improvement is is
an overlap right everybody right
everybody should strive to become you
know something approaching
approaching the best version of of
themselves physically
mentally spiritually personality like
you know
all of that um but what men are
attracted to and what
women are attracted to it's not the same
you know anyone who tells you that is a
liar
yeah they're deluded you know it's not
it's not the same thing which is how you
get these silly situations where you
know
a woman is like some high-flying career
woman or whatever
or has like a dick has a master's degree
or a phd and she's like yeah but like
i've got this i've got that and you know
i'm like men don't care like yeah
the girl who works in mcdonald's and
looks hot and feminine
is more attractive than the woman making
six figures
and whatever like unless she's also got
those attractive female qualities
guys don't generally just don't care
about that stuff but because
a lot of women are attracted to that or
attracted to you know statements
etc then they assume that guys are and
i'm just like no
it's not how it is no it's not how it's
ever been either that's the first
it's not how it's ever been um and i
think that
you know feminism perhaps has overshot
so much that people are in this delusion
where they think okay men are men and
women are literally
the same and interchangeable and it's
like no and of course like where there's
nuance in all of this every single
person's an individual
has a different personality has a
different set of values different things
they're after
so it's not you know a one-size-fits-all
but generally speaking um just like i
could give advice you know generally
for a guy you know the advice generally
for a woman
would be um it would be different it
would be different i'd i'd also say like
actually for women it's a
heck of a lot easier i disagree i think
okay okay let's go no here we go
i think that it's easier for men dating
than women okay tell me tell me because
here's the thing
women um they have
a timeline right because you have to
what you're 35
to get married like basically if you
want to have kids right
yeah roughly speaking and i just think
everyone you don't want to leave it too
late
yeah and i just think everything's worse
when you know you have like a clock
ticking where guys have they could be 50
and still have kids if they wanted to
sure but yeah i mean you've still got a
long time i mean you got like well
that's like two decades
two decades what do you mean two no it's
like what are you gonna get married
like between 20 22. okay let's say women
have like
what that's that's still like 15 years
yeah okay
that's a long time and most and most
guys also don't
really actually want to wait until 50. i
mean you you can yeah
most guys don't want to so yeah sure men
have a longer window in that regard
but uh yeah i mean the
yeah the the game is heavily tilted
towards females i
i i believe in my opinion there are
certain there's no doubt that there are
certain things that are uh shall we say
easier like tilted in male in the male
favor and there are things that are
tilted
in the female favor but i think
generally certainly in the west
certainly in the modern west i think
it's uh
it's a it's a it's a women's market more
than it's a man's market if you're like
in the top ten percent of guys then you
may think and feel very very differently
on this right for the average the
average woman compared to the average
guy
right not even close if you're talking
like the tip top like you know a top
guy and however you want to rate that um
versus you know an average then that's
that's different but
i don't know i thought i designed to be
an average dude i just well i think that
men
they can like become the things that
women want
right i don't think women like you're
kind of bored you look how you look
mm-hmm no no
no no so no
no no most women can be attractive
oh most women can be and in fact men are
attracted to most women
most guys won't admit this but most men
are attracted to most women unless
they've like
actually gone out of their way to
make themselves unattractive huh
yeah which which which can be a pretty
high percentage actually even if you
just
look at i don't know obesity for example
like huge yeah
yeah i mean if you look at if you look
at pictures from
just look at pictures from the 1970s or
1960s like most women are attractive
most of them are attractive i will say
that the one thing that you can't
overcome is being
short as a guy to be born
short yeah it's a it's a it's a
disadvantage i mean
no i mean like look if if a woman keeps
her is at healthy body
weight and you know gross you know has a
nice nice hair style and just
dresses nicely and is just you know
somewhat feminine
then i mean that already puts her in
probably like
top i don't know 25 right that's not
right like that's not a huge issue
it depends on where you are like if you
go to like central europe or eastern
europe then
no like that's not going to be at the
top but like
honestly the amount of people even young
people who this goes for men too who
just let themselves go
already by the age of like 20 is pretty
pretty bonkers i mean i i also think
most men can be attractive like i think
most
i think most people could be attractive
with like some moderate effort and
care yeah yeah like like honestly you
know i mean if you
take any guy off the street um you know
whatever it's like okay get him get him
in the gym and eating well for like
a year to two years like get him a
decent haircut
like if he's wearing like just bad
style like terrible clothes just like
you know swap that
yeah it's like okay like he'll even
physically he'll like already look like
pretty decent and then yeah you know
other things you know
confidence humor all that like there's
there's more to it but
a lot of people the truth is a lot of
people don't put put very little
appearance
into even trying to be attractive that's
that's the truth like both men and women
like a lot of people just don't even
try and then a lot of times once people
are in relationships they try even less
like they just like
whatever like yeah and so merely trying
you're merely putting in some effort
whether you're a man or a woman
already is um yeah in this day and age
like that's already
that's already something that's already
something yeah
yeah that's i think he won this argument
i'm not gonna
idea i do i do
i do think about these things a lot i've
thought about them from like a pretty
young age to be honest
i'm new to the madness i actually didn't
realize until
recently the way people treat you
different just because you're a girl
and i i did not realize that until super
recently like
mine i do not realize that well because
you just think
everyone's treated like that i don't
know
what what specifically do you mean well
okay i'll give you i'll give you an
example right
i do um rap reactions on my account
right so um my boyfriend he's very like
into like super like um freed up frito
bang
i think his name is yeah
those guys um i i don't i don't listen
to that that's not i listened to country
and he thought it was really funny
watching me like react to these videos
because i didn't know what they meant
um it was like a steppa i didn't know
what that meant um i still don't
but he i wanted to get like a
collab with the rapper and get a
reaction and like they'll respond to me
but he has
over a million followers on instagram
and like they don't respond to him
just because i'm a girl you know what
i'm saying just because i'm a girl
yeah yeah so there you go this is what
i'm talking about about
the world being easier for you yeah
it might sometimes be it might sometimes
be for the wrong reasons but it's just
how it is
i just proved your point but sorry i
think i think i just went over our time
uh but this is fine it's fine this was
so fun though
um thank you so much for coming on i
know you have a bigger platform than me
so i was
actually really excited that you said
yes no die you're welcome
you're welcome well if people want to
check my stuff out you can follow me
at zooby music on all platforms twitter
instagram facebook youtube
and um if you go to zoobeemusic.com
i've got all of my music podcasts
merch links to everything on there so
you can check that out